let's Instead try George from Virginia
George from Virginia welcome
George from Virginia you're on
George from Virginia you almost
certainly have the wrong audio device
selected
oh there you go now you're back okay
sorry about that
um so uh yeah thanks for taking my call
I really enjoy your show
um I wanted to bring up something that's
kind of been bothering me lately
um if you look at like
the media and even like independent
creators in the left uh space sure I've
seen a lot of fawning over uh Pete
bootage Edge and
I wanted to ask you do you think there's
like a tendency
for people and especially the media to
kind of focus on like
the you know he does so well in
interviews like he owns uh Republican so
well but if you look at his job
performance it's I'm just not seeing it
you're saying that as Secretary of
Transportation you don't think his
performance has been good exactly yeah
so here's the thing there's two
different conversations here George
right one conversation is do we think
that in terms of image and performance
he's the type of person who could win an
election and then secondly is the
analysis of how do we evaluate his job
performance as Secretary of
Transportation on the second part I
don't have an answer in the sense that
he's been getting blamed for stuff that
really has nothing to do with him to be
totally honest including like for
example the global supply chain issues
like that's not Pete bootage's fault the
FAA thing I don't know from what I've
read it it doesn't really seem like it's
his fault but let's let me put that
aside for a sec
what I think makes Pete butterjudge an
interesting potential presidential
candidate is that he has a number of
characteristics that make him a good
modern presidential candidate and what I
mean by that is yes he is very good in
adversarial think on your feet positions
particularly with bad faith
right-wingers that actually matters
right now when you think about how you
become the nominee and eventually the
president number two he has enough
policy ideas in enough areas you can
talk to people to judge about
Transportation electric cars foreign
policy China education Latin America and
he's not going to get embarrassed on any
issue and he'll probably have at least
an idea to put forward on any one of
those issues that's really important he
won't come off as a buffoon on any issue
um he's well spoken you know so so do
you understand the difference between
the two analyzes that we're doing
yes yeah I I understand that so I'm just
more than willing to entertain the job
performance things you're bringing up I
think they are basically at this point
for better or worse completely divorced
from whether he would be a good
candidate it's sort of like Gavin Newsom
I'm not like a huge fan of Gavin
newsom's politics necessarily but I do
think he has an attitude that is useful
for Democrats to have when it comes to
Republicans in 2023 so he's the type of
guy who might do well in a campaign even
if he's not like the Uber Progressive or
the guy I would say this is who I would
love to see as president
yeah I I think you make a lot of valid
points um but uh just to end my uh
opinion here I just wanted to say like
I'm a little bit worried because
there's so many Americans who have been
impacted by the airline situations yeah
and if Democrats push this guy Center
Stage even if he speaks well and all
that people might be like no this guy
sucks you know he the airlines were
horrible under him and I feel like it
could sabotage the Democrats if they
choose a guy like this that's always
possible I mean now you're making a
prediction and I'm terrible at
predictions so you may well be right it
may end up being a terrible
self-sabotage or not I just don't know
well I I really appreciate your opinion
and uh thank you very much all right
George from Virginia uh appreciate the
discussion very very much